hello everybody very good morning to you
it is seven o'clock and you are very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on sky news let's start with the
news about a bloody battle for
steelworks in the besieged ukrainian
city of mario paul we're hearing from a
commander at the heart of it this
morning and we'll talk to the former
head of the british army general lord
danette and the former british
ambassador to russia that's the andrew
wood it's thursday the 5th of may
heavy bloody battles a ukrainian
commander inside the mario paul
steelworks under attack speaks out as
russian forces attempt to take it
i'm in the capital kiev where president
zielenski says efforts will continue to
rescue people from mario pole with more
than 300 recently evacuated
polls have opened in elections across
the united kingdom with thousands of
council seats being contested across
england wales and scotland while voters
in northern ireland have their say on
the assembly
bank of england is expected to increase
interest rates to the highest level in
more than a decade we ask what it means
for you
holding back tears the actress amber
heard gives her first evidence in the
johnny depp libel trial
this is the most painful and difficult
thing i've ever gone through
for sure
beijing tightens restrictions as it
tackles a rise in covert cases with
schools and gyms shut
hand of what maradona's iconic shirt has
been sold but for how much we'll discuss
that and its history after 9 30.
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching
around the world should elephants be
kept in zoos we'll speak to chester zoo
as a new report calls for the gentle
giants to be set free
[Music]
you're the one that i need on stage can
a new production of greece stand up to
the 70s classic we'll find out when we
speak to the actress starring as sandy
and the choreographer dame arlene
phillips
[Music]
hello everyone a very good morning we
begin with the bloody battle for a
steelworks in the besieged ukrainian
city of mariopol a commander of the
ukrainian azov regiment holding the line
at the complex claims russia forces have
been attempting to storm the plant two
days running he's described the heavy
bloody battles taking place
video from the denex people's republic
shows what appears to be the as of style
steelworks under heavy bombing
sky news has verified the video's
location to the as of style plant but
the date of the footage remains unknown
since the 25th of april we have been
holding a circular defense at the azov
style plant
it is already the second day that the
enemy broke into the plant there are
heavy bloody battles
i am proud of my soldiers for making
inhuman efforts to contain the enemy's
onslaught i thank the whole world for
the tremendous support of the mariopole
garrison
our soldiers deserve it the situation is
extremely difficult but we continue to
carry out the order to keep the defense
despite everything
well more than 300 civilians have now
arrived in zaparizia after being rescued
from mario paul and the surrounding
areas in evacuations coordinated by the
un and the red cross
president zielenski has rescued those
still trapped in the besieged city and
he says it's not going to be easy but he
was hopeful they too could be saved
we agree and hope to continue rescuing
people from as of stall and mario
there are still civilians women children
to save them we have to continue the
regime of silence
the ukrainian side is ready to provide
it
it takes time just to get people out of
the basements
from those hiding places underground
under the current conditions we cannot
use special equipment to clear the
rubble
everything is done by hand
but we believe that everything will work
out
let's bring in debris standing by in
kiev for us as usual this morning i say
as usual buddy of course you've been
there a long time now haven't you uh
deborah the the fighting goes on two
things to talk about i suppose mario
paul to start with
yes it's an absolutely desperate
situation the foreign minister was
speaking to mark austin yesterday about
the avastol evacuation efforts the un is
at the heart of trying to negotiate safe
passage for those civilians still
trapped under there and it the fact that
they haven't been able to get everybody
out just underlines the lack of trust
between the two sides russia's military
claimed that there would be humanitarian
corridors for civilians today tomorrow
and the next day but as you can see at
the same time they are also bombarding
the area given that this is the last
remaining stronghold of ukrainian
resistance in a city that is otherwise
under the control of russian forces and
these people have been under there for
months now
without proper access to food water
medical supplies for those who are
unwell there are elderly people there
there are children there it doesn't bear
thinking about and you can feel
listening to ukrainian government
officials talking about it just how
painful this is but also just how
important that ukrainian resistance has
been in terms of drawing in russian
firepower and preventing russia from
being able to claim a victory over this
strategic city and something i also
wanted to touch on if i may please
deborah is um the direct hits on um a
theater where we believe up to a
thousand civilians had been sheltering
from the bombing at the time we were
told that potentially 300 people had
died latest reports from an
international wire service suggesting
that could be more than double
yes so the associated press has done a
stunning investigation into what
happened on that 16th of march attack a
russian air strike on this theater that
had been used as a shelter by civilians
by women by children huddling there
hoping for rescue from mariupol and
instead they had they'd written
children in white letters on the ground
in big enough letters for russian planes
to be able to see that
russia initially has denied doing it
blaming the ukrainians then saying the
ukrainians have been using that theater
for
soldiers none of that
has been substantiated by evidence the
absolute contrary in fact the um the
witnesses that that the ap has spoken to
um talk about how women and children
have been sheltered there and then were
killed there by this airstrike those who
survived stepping over the bodies of the
dead and actually now given that the
area is under russian control the
ability to be able to independently
count the number of dead is impossible
and yes like you say the witnesses um
saying that they believe up to 600
people could have been killed in that
airstrike which would make it the
deadliest attack single attack of this
war so far okay deborah for now thank
you thanks a lot
well joining us now is a former british
ambassador to russia that's uh andrew
wood hello to sir andrew thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
absolutely shocking news coming out of
mariopol both at the steelworks and also
the number of dead um as a result of
what appears to be a russian targeted
strike on a theater where women and
children were sheltering
horrible
they don't care
the russians and they lie about it
anyway
i understand um
where do you think this is going to end
mr ambassador we know that um next
monday i think is is a big day isn't it
it's a victory day
in um
in moscow in russia and
it had been thought that by then um
putin had thought this war would be won
what do you think will happen now well
he thought he was going to win it a long
time before
but in fact he's he's losing heavily
and i think we have to realize that he
cannot win the war
in the sense of
achieving
a settled outcome
nobody in ukraine
is going to forget what he's done and
what his forces have done
and the way they have done it
that in itself is a defeat
secondly
it is apparently
the case
that he's already lost more
russian troops to death
than they lost during the
war in afghanistan
i think he's in a terrible fix in that
way
but russian propaganda is
completely
it doesn't care about the truth anyway
so presumably he will try to work up
some sort of story
probably that it's all our fault
um
but i think he's an impossible position
uh we are being told by the kremlin that
uh president putin is still open to
talks with uh president zielenski do you
believe him
well i'm sure he's open to talks with
the landscape provided zielinski agrees
to russian conditions whatever they are
at that moment
there is no
i don't think it could be any real
dialogue until
the results in
the eastern region are clear
if russia continues to lose troops at
the rate they are
then they can have talks about russia
retreating essentially
if he if he if he wins
in the sense of slaughtering more
russians
sorry that's sort of more ukrainians
[Music]
it still isn't a victory because it's
not a permanent solution to anything
we also must keep an eye on what bella
russia is up to
um we are being told that they're
conducting military
drills um how much of a threat do you
think this might be to ukraine
well if belarus was
ready to
send his troops in and mobility and
mobilize fully it would of course be an
increased threat
but the belarusians so far have been
extremely cautious about doing anything
and some belarusians at least have
decided to fight on behalf of the
ukrainians
so i think lukashenka has to
watch his control over his own country
which is already fragile
so again i think it's something which
may happen
but i do not believe it's going to be a
full-scale invasion from belarus
um just hearing from the ministry of
defence this morning saying russia will
likely seek to inflate the threat posed
by ukraine opposed to ukraine uh by the
exercises that we are hearing about in
uh belarussia um
and ordering to fix ukrainian forces in
the north preventing them from being
committed to the battle for donbass i
suppose that is that's a reasonable
theory isn't it
it's a reasonable theory and if it
happened of course it would be
a
a threat to to ukraine
i do not think however it will produce a
surrender to russian conditions
or belarusian conditions
from ukraine ukrainian president
is uh
it's holding its own very very well
indeed
and it's
revealed the fact
that the russian army and i would
believe the belarusian army as well
is of limited
experience and skills
it's uh
it's a
we all believed or most of us believe
that if the russians did invade
uh in
february
it would be quite a quick win for them
because the numbers of troops
and because of the
idea that we all had about their
effectivity
but i think we forgot
that the russians have actually had
rather little
experience of fighting hand-hand or
between troops
what they did in syria for example is
flattened cities just as they
did flatten the cities when they
hit war against chechnya
um
and as they
would have done if had they felt it
necessary
in in georgia
controlled and
widescaled fighting
has not been their
skill
and their uh
effect has been very poor from that
point of view
because
as i understand from military and i
can't pretend to have done it myself
but it is a complex thing which they
have not
succeeded in in doing
what more do you think
britain could be doing at the moment and
indeed why do europe
i think what britain is doing at present
is uh um
stalwart and effective
it's certainly
won the affection of ukrainians
and it's also
increased britain's standing
and attitudes in the whole of eastern
[Music]
eastern eu if you like
i was recently in
in estonia for example
and um
our word had quite a lot of value to it
the idea that finland and sweden may
also join the eu
now
is uh
it's it's it's an absolutely radical
change
and a radical change for russia
i can only hope
that in the end the putin regime will
take account of some new realities
and
be different
you said graciously
oh yeah indeed so um mr ambassador it's
always a pleasure to speak to you thank
you for taking the time to join us on
the breakfast show on sky this morning
thank you
thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this morning in the next hour speaking
to the former head of the british army
general lord danette as reports emerge
of uh russian soldiers soldiers i should
say attempting to storm the mario pole
steel
steelworks
[Music]
joined by a university student doing her
part to help people fleeing the fighting
in ukraine by donating sanitary products
to those most in need
and the world health organization is
warning of a crisis of epidemic
proportions with more than one million
obesity related deaths in europe each
year we'll hear from the gp dr david
lloyd
ali's with us talk about the good
morning
bank of england why yes because we are
expecting interest rates to rise the
context of this of course is soaring
inflation that the bank of england are
grappling with we heard the governor of
the bank of england previously talking
about trying to balance growth versus
inflation today we expect this lunch
time that base interest rates could be
raised from 0.75
to 1 that is a 13-year high the fourth
month in a row that we've seen the bank
of england doing this why does this
matter for ordinary people because it
might help people potentially with
savings although it does take time for
those sorts of savings to get through to
consumers but it is bad for people who
are in debt and people that have
mortgages because for example fixed rate
more variable rate mortgages rather
could become um more expensive in terms
of how much you're actually paying back
so this could have an impact on a lot of
people as i say inflation has soared you
know it hit seven percent back in march
it's not just a uk problem it's a
worldwide problem in the us the national
reserve there raised their interest
rates to a range between 1.75 and one
just yesterday in australia we've seen
interest rates raised in india to
global problems things like ukraine the
covid lockdown in china having an impact
on all this but we expect that decision
from the bank of england this lunchtime
kay she's a beautiful building isn't she
the uh bank of england oh yeah yeah do
you trivial question for you do you know
what she's called oh my gosh
you'll never forget now the old lady of
threadneedle street okay great knowledge
yeah i mean you know every day is a
school day so we'll find out at midday
today what's going to happen
spoiler alert i did get an email from my
bank saying we're very sorry that
interest rates have gone up and we were
here to help blah blah blah and then two
hours later this was earlier in the week
cheers lately they wrote back and said
we sent that in error so i think we know
where we're going with expectations okay
okay thanks a lot
uh let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you now should we and
polls have opened in elections across
the uk more than 4 350 seats are being
contested in england on over 140
councils with all of scotland's 32
councils and all 22 councils in wales
also holding local elections boaters in
northern ireland are electing
representatives to the stormont assembly
polling stations close at 10 tonight
a virgin atlantic flight was forced to
turn around half an hour after it took
off after it emerged that one of the
pilots
had not completed all of the training
required by the company it happened on
monday as the flight was on its way to
new york from heathrow
how would you feel if you were on that
flight
furious that you had to turn back but
also glad that you did now the premiere
of the british at virgin islands andrew
fahey will plead not guilty to drug
trafficking mr fah he was arrested last
week in miami by agents from the u.s
drug enforcement agency posing as
mexican drug traffickers he's been
granted bail ahead of his upcoming trial
right now if you are a blue in
manchester real madrid have beaten
manchester city an extra time in the
champions league semi-final
the match finished 3-1 on the night 6-5
on aggregate it sets up a final between
liverpool and real in paris
on the 28th of may
beijing has announced new lockdown
restrictions to limit the spread of
covid19 gyms and schools will be closed
indefinitely and restaurants limited to
takeaways what on earth is going on
tom's in beijing for us hi tom i was
reading uh bill gates and what he his
views are and what's happening in china
at the moment you're the man on the
ground what's going on
morning k yeah it feels really like a
slow motion lockdown we had a public
holiday over the last few days and they
announced these temporary measures uh
the restaurants would be sharp the
schools would be shocked that gyms would
be sharp those temporary measures have
turned out uh to be a bit longer lasting
they're being extended indefinitely as
beijing tries to get on top of this one
of the royals they're doing that is mass
testing so this district chao yang three
and a half million people we've had to
get three tests on three consecutive
days you can see one of the booths
behind me around beijing some 20 million
people took three tests last week so
they can try and map the spread of this
now the numbers we're looking at have
been pretty steady around 50 a day but
they are worried about that and they
want to avoid a full lockdown like we've
seen in shanghai you might remember the
scenes over the last few weeks people
really when we say lockdown it's much
more severe than anything that's seen in
the uk or even australia people confined
to their homes they have to rely on the
government to deliver food often weren't
getting enough food and we saw lots of
protests as a result of that that's what
beijing wants to avoid it feels like it
has caught it's got on top of things
earlier than shanghai did the good news
for shanghai though is it looks like it
might be coming to the end of that
lockdown cases have dropped a lot there
around 25 000 a day at its peak and
they're now around 5000 so perhaps some
hope those restrictions will be but this
is all part of zero covert it is here to
stay so the rest of the world is opening
up it feels a bit surreal to be going
through potentially another lockdown
here in beijing right now it remains
really in the balance
okay i suppose the question that a lot
of people are asking our viewers are
asking this morning though tom is is
what's happening there as serious as it
potentially was last time and is it
heading our way
i mean what they're dealing with here is
omicron the same thing that the rest of
the world is dealing with and the reason
they're doing they're not doing it the
same way as the rest of the world is
because of the low vaccination rate
especially amongst the elderly
especially because they've been using
chinese vaccines they refuse to import
western mrna vaccines which seem to be
more effective against omicron and then
you've got a very weak medical system on
top so china has taken the decision that
if it were to open up it would lead to a
catastrophic wave across china which
could bring risks for the rest of the
world if you imagine a population of 1.4
billion people not high levels of
vaccination amongst the elderly there's
the potential for new variants to emerge
here in china and who knows what they
could look like so china's looked at
that and said despite the pain of this
on the personal level on the economic
level because this is costing china and
it's starting to cost the world as well
in terms of supply chains uh it's hard
to get uh parts from one factory to
another in this country let alone get
them out of the country on a container
ship when you've got shanghai the
biggest port city in the world operating
under those restrictions but china says
despite all that it is much riskier to
try and open up so they're going to
stick with measures like this for a long
time to come okay thank you thanks a lot
well the actress aberhood has given her
first evidence in the libel trial with
johnny depp sometimes seeming close to
tears a warning this report from our
arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer contains descriptions of
abuse
will you please state your name
yes it's amber laura heard her
ex-husband had given evidence
now this was amber heard's turn
i struggle to find the words to describe
how
painful this is
this is
the most painful and difficult thing
i've ever gone through
for sure she set out how their romance
began on the press tour for the 2011
film they made together a whirlwind of
passion and lavish gifts
when i was around johnny i felt like the
most beautiful person in the world
you know made me feel seen made me feel
like a million dollars
interspersed with depp's drinking binges
and signs of his controlling behavior
he would make these comments about
you know
myself out but do so in the context of
me acting
every
time i was walking out of the house i
he would ask me that's really what
you're wearing kid you know like when
i'm standing there you know just hit the
wall screaming at me
um
but
then he would um disappear
and get clean and sober and he'd come
back and tell me
that he
was done drinking the first time he'd
hit her she claimed was after she'd
laughed at his tattoo
and he slaps me one more time
hard
i lose my balance um at this point we're
sitting next to each other on the edge
of the couch i was on the edge of the
couch
and
i'm
all of a sudden
realizing that the worst thing has just
happened to me
god did he just hit me
the court also heard graphic details of
a sexual assault she said she suffered
as depp searched her body claiming she
was hiding cocaine from him
he said he was looking for his drugs his
cocaine his coke while derp in his
evidence has claimed he was in fact the
victim of domestic violence heard has
said that at his worst she feared him
and felt lonely and trapped
katie spencer sky news
of course that case continues now the
first covered lockdown saw people flee
to the country in search of space and
fresh air but scania's analysis has
found that many are now choosing to
return to the city
as you can see looking at our graphics
for year population growth in parts of
north london and salford has been far
above that of the english average and
having stagnated or even gone down over
the lockdown's rents in london and
manchester are once again on the rise
well aisha is standing by for us in
central london in fact i think i'm
writing staying here in piccadilly
circus looking at what's behind you
there tell us more i should good morning
morning well all of this comes down to
the fact that in terms of opportunities
cities have
more opportunities both in terms of work
and also socially now the sky news data
team looked at a couple of things first
of all gp records they're a good
indicator of where people are moving to
and they showed that more people have
moved to london and manchester they're
the two popular cities and then also
they looked at rent
now rent has seen an increase beyond
pre-pandemic levels and it was greater
manchester where it was highest around
12.5
and as you've said when looking within
london and manchester the most popular
areas seem to be north west london and
salford just outside manchester city
centre both saw population grow by
around six percent and when it came to
ages uh that it was an increase across
all age groups but in particular for
london and manchester it was an increase
in people in their 40s moving to these
areas and then looking at liverpool the
number of people in their 30s increased
by nearly seven percent although
birmingham seemed to buck the trend uh
it saw a reduction in the number of
people in their 20s living there and
like i said all of this coming down to
both work opportunities but the number
of uh social opportunities too
okay um capital city of england uh
waking up this thursday morning thanks
very much indeed aisha thank you
close look at why people are deciding to
return to the city joining us now joe is
recently made the decision to move away
from the suburbs back to the city hi joe
good to see you thanks for joining us
why why did you decide that suburban
life was not for you
um during the kind of lockdown period um
i was isolating with my parents um back
in the outskirts of west yorkshire and
during that time i was working remotely
like many people my age in my sort of
industry work
and we were very much used to working
remotely
but throughout my whole life i've very
much been a city person i've liked the
aspect of socializing networking and
also having accessibility to work in an
office environment
during the pandemic i was offered pretty
much my dream job
and i was approached by embryo and which
is the digital marketing agency that i
work for i'm the head of pr there and
the position was in manchester's where
the office is located so kind of during
the period of the last part of that
lockdown and i was working remotely with
the rest of the staff and then i was
able to relocate last april so i've been
living now in manchester for just over a
year
and how is it living in the city rather
than living in the suburbs do you enjoy
it more is there much more to do i
suppose it's very different um because
of course when you're in the suburbs it
was locked down so there was you
couldn't do very much anyway
yeah definitely i think suburb life has
its perks you know being able to kind of
reconnect with nature definitely during
the lockdown periods you know being able
to go for walks runs having that
accessibility to have that kind of daily
exercise which were recommended at the
time
but i really craved um being able to
socialize i'm very much an extrovert as
a personality and that's something that
i definitely struggled with with having
many friends that didn't live nearby
um so being able to relocate into a city
again when things were easing up where
people were able to eat out again
socialize um in a kind of two meter
distance format was great and also just
to meet my team as well face to face
which was a lovely
experience good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining us good
luck with a new job thank you
welcome
the show the shirt i should say worn by
the footballer diego maradona when he
scored what he called his hand of god
goal has sold for more than seven
million pounds at auction during the
1986 world cup quarter-final the ball
clearly hit the argentina's player's arm
i think it was his hand actually before
going into the net for the first goal
that game saw england knocked out of the
tournament the buyer of the iconic shirt
is still
unknown
there we go
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it'll be fine for most today but patchy
rain in the northwest will become
heavier later before spreading south on
friday england and wales are quite
chilly at the moment while scotland
ireland and northern ireland are milder
but much cloudier with a little patchy
rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
who doesn't fancy a bit of dolly parton
first thing in the morning she said
she's honored and humbled to accept her
induction into the rock and roll hall of
fame
bitter jolie
[Music]
i once went to the grand ole opry and
they uh they honor her there as well in
nashville tennessee but i've never been
to dolly world have you
let me know country music legend had
initially resisted the honor saying she
hadn't earned the right and would
respectfully bow out but the hall of
fame said the decision was up to voters
and the 76 year old has now been
inducted eminem lionel richie and duran
duran were also given the honor which is
amazing lionel richie's son her daughter
actually just recently become
engaged which is amazing isn't it and i
know the guy that she is marrying he is
an absolute legend now some of the
funniest moments in british sitcom
history immortalized in lego fan from
slovenia has been recreating famous
scenes from only horses
only fools and horses why was i saying
only horses and fools it's that time of
the morning including the iconic moment
where dell falls through the open bar
that is hilarious if you've never seen
it zazo zibbert got the idea after
watching repeats of the show on
slovenian television
have you ever wondered what a baby
squirrel looks like
there it is
can move in a bit closer matt and show
them here's a remarkable photograph of a
red squirrel carrying its kit in its
mouth as it climbs a tree the image was
captured by photographer john mcrobbie
during a walk at loch levin in scotland
you'll know of course that we don't see
um the
red squirrel in much of the united
kingdom anymore i think a bit in
lancashire up in cumbria lake district
area there and then up towards scotland
grey squirrel much bigger uh squirrel
than the red squirrel uh and the world's
only non-oblates
nine babies from the same birth have
celebrated their first
birthdays oh my goodness me can you
imagine it was hard enough with one the
babies are still being cared for by the
specialist clinic in morocco where they
were born their dad says they are all in
perfect
health
can you imagine when they've all got a
cob on all at the same time goodness me
well done mum and dad now joined by a
university student doing her part to
help people fleeing the fighting in
ukraine by donating sanitary products to
those in need that come in just a moment
[Music]
top stories for you on the breakfast
show here on sky news this thursday
morning more than 300 civilians have
been evacuated from mario paul as
russia's assaults on the devastated
ukrainian city continues
polls have opened in elections across
the uk with thousands of council seats
being contested across england wales and
scotland while voters in northern
ireland have their say on the assembly
bank of england is expected to raise the
base rates of interest to its highest
level in more than a decade
[Music]
now a former british ambassador to
russia has told this programme that
president putin cannot win the war in
ukraine though a set through a settled
outcome and that his forces are
suffering heavy losses i began by asking
sir andrew for his reaction to the
attacks on the mario pole steel works in
theater
horrible
they don't care
the russians
and they lie about it anyway we know
that
next monday i think is is a big day
isn't it it's a victory day
in um
in moscow in russia and
it had been thought that by then um
putin had thought this war would be won
what do you think will happen now
well he thought he was going to win it a
long time before
but in fact he's he's losing heavily
and i think we have to realize that he
cannot win the war
in the sense of
achieving
a settled outcome
nobody in ukraine
is going to forget what he's done and
what his forces have done
and the way they have done it
that in itself is a defeat
secondly
it is apparently
the case
that he's already lost more
russian troops to death
than they lost during the
war in afghanistan
as millions of people fled the fighting
in ukraine a student at bristol
university wanted to find a way that she
could help ella lambert travel to poland
to help distribute period products to
refugees who'd made their way to warsaw
ella is with us now ella it's one of
those things that you you know people
fleeing war and people don't think about
that sort of thing but it's a plague for
very many women and thankfully people
like you have come to their aid tell us
more
absolutely i think the thing is with
these situations when you have a
conflict when you have any situation
where people in poverty
and period poverty is inevitable because
if you have to pack your bag and leave
within minutes without knowing where
you're going the chance that you
remember to
pack period products is really unlikely
and if you do they run out and so a year
and a half ago during the first lockdown
i set up an organization to make
reusable sanitary pads like this there's
one here which is made with ukrainian
mind um
to distribute all over the world to
refugees who can't really afford
products
and so they last 35 years
and really sought people out for the
foreseeable future
and so obviously when everything
happened with ukraine just over two
months ago um we realized as an
organization that you know millions of
new refugees we have a part to play in
this and we have to make sure that
property is on the top of the gender for
organizations and that we ourselves are
doing something about it
um and so we got together with pads for
refugees and american ngo and we've
raised over 7 000 pounds and
distributed what i myself distributed
pads to a thousand women in warsaw in
one of the refugee centers
and we're sending reusable pads to two
thousand women in the leaf um in ukraine
and to be sent off to hospitals in the
east where supermarkets have really run
and drive the most basic products and
new mothers are going to need these
products as opposed parting pads
you've had a lot of help haven't you as
well others have come along to to help
you produce these products
yeah absolutely i mean it has been
amazing we have over over 1 500
volunteers now in nine different
countries
um and
yeah i mean we had 200 new volunteer
inquiries um after the war in ukraine
broke out and i think that really shows
this like wave of empathy that people
are feeling right now for ukraine
um and that people really want to help
and i think that's really beautiful
and that's what i saw in warsaw as well
that you know people are opening their
homes opening their arms giving every
possible aid that they can give um
but i will say that right now seeing
what's going on with the uk government
you know bringing in this policy to send
people off to rwanda i want people to
really think about if this happened to
you tomorrow because it really could as
we've seen
what would what response would you want
to receive when you fled your country
would you want to receive what
ukrainians have experienced right now or
yeah i'm gonna have to stop you there
i'm so sorry but um because of the day
that it is today we can't really talk
about politics in any way shape or form
so i'm just gonna have to leave it there
but you do get our hero of the day for
uh the amazing work that you were doing
and thinking outside the box thank you
so much for joining us on the program
thank you
thank you so much thanks a lot
for the fourth month in a row the bank
of england is later expected to raise
the base rate of interest pushing it to
its highest level since 2009.
martha de souza is a property expert and
developer and she is with us now hi
master thanks very much indeed for
joining us um lots of homeowners
especially with mortgages of course
looking with some trepidation towards at
midday today what sort of problems might
it cause
well it's tough we've had record low
interest rates for such a long time that
people's perception of what they can
afford has been severely altered um that
we have had very low rates with these
rising weights and the expectation that
they'll rise to around 2.5 percent per
year we could see a little bit of a
slowdown in the housing market i say
this because the housing market is
extremely robust last month we had also
another growth in house prices they've
grown yet again
but with inflation rising at a to a
30-year high and increasing energy
prices and again these interest rates
going up affordability of homes is going
to be hard um the robust uh housing
market has continued through the
pandemic we've had again increased
growth as well once again 14.3 percent
at some points and um i i really feel
like um these interest rates may dampen
uh the growth but
not substantially that there's a lot of
momentum the people that will struggle
however are those on um variable
interest rates not fixed rates on their
mortgage and again those mortgage
prisoners that are stuck with very low
equity in properties those are the ones
that will truly be harmed by this rate
rise
okay um you say um a slowing in the
price of property can you are you
potentially anticipating a fall
can you still hear me
oh i think i might have a lot of smarter
can you give me now
yes i can yes yes okay i was just asking
you you talked about as slowing in the
uh house prices
would you answer to anticipate
potentially a fall in some areas
well i i do think in some areas of the
country yes however i don't foresee the
huge fall and the huge um price market
check that a lot of experts are
predicting that's because they predicted
it for this um kovid pandemic year it
didn't happen um and that's also to do
with a very simple economic
problem it's the supply and demand when
interest rates go up people don't want
to move it costs them to move as well
people will hold on to their properties
lack of supply what does that mean
demand is still going to go up and but
we're going to have uh prices still
keeping quite high i do think it will
slow down so we're not going to have
these record growths i mean we we saw
record growth by nationwide last month
once again um but we are going to see a
bit of a slowdown and in some areas of
the country that have been uh you know
like london that have been increasingly
fast we may see in some areas a little
bit of a decrease um will it be enough
to make homes affordable at 265 000
pounds like they have been uh last month
so record average price as well once
again pushing through that barrier once
again um i i don't foresee a huge check
in the market the uk housing prices are
always very strong and they continue to
surprise us
uh just before i let you go uh martial
what do you make of this latest survey
suggesting that we saw people flooding
into the suburbs during the lockdowns
and the pandemic but now bored with that
and coming back into the cities
yes it always happens whenever there's a
big crisis it happened during the london
bombings people fled out of london only
to move back in um it was expected that
people a few people would stay out
because of zoom and all other types of
um
online work but they have come back in
because people want to be where uh where
the buzz is where their friends are or
where they can go to restaurants where
they're the high streets are we're
social human beings and i do think that
that will be a continued trend you will
always come back into the cities and
that's why the cities are appealing to
live in and why you've got a house price
of an average house price of 565 000 in
central london and 265 for the rest of
the country people want to live where uh
more people are so yes um i do think it
will continue um to go through that
trend and we'll see um people moving
back into the major cities
okay great to talk to you thanks the
analysis much appreciated
and a reminder that we'll be hearing
more about what's going to happen to
interest rates at midday
today and ally will be coming back onto
the show in just a short time to explain
what it might mean
for you it looks as though interest
rates could go to the highest level in
more than a decade of course you find
about it find out about it first here on
sky news meantime there's been anger in
the u.s over a move that could make
abortions illegal in some states
here's martha kendall she's been
speaking to campaigners about what
options women could be left with i just
want to warn you this report contains an
interview describing home abortions
america is facing off and facing up to
the likelihood that half of its states
will soon make abortion illegal
many of these protesters weren't alive
in 1973 when access to abortion was
enshrined in the constitution in a
ruling known as roe versus wade
this woman was carol downer recalls a
time when abortion was criminalized she
can't believe it's happening again
it is a blow
we are going to be hurt very badly
by this
carol helped create an underground
network of women who performed home
abortions teaching them how to use this
instrument the material goes out through
the tubing into the jar
known as the dell m carroll calls it
menstrual extraction and it can be used
to terminate a pregnancy she thinks more
women may turn back to using it well i'm
just very happy we have it i guess
i mean i'm mad that we have to have it
but i want to see women you know not
shamed
to
learn about their bodies and that's
taking charge of it
and then not having a doctor who can say
whether you know
in many times whether he will be willing
to do the procedure postering painting
murals other groups are launching
information campaigns about abortion
pills which can be delivered by post for
women in restrictive states
these activists took those pills outside
the supreme court they say to prove they
are safe this court cannot stop us we
will get the medication to the people
who need it and we will share
information about abortion pills and
where to get access because this is a
fundamental human right
26 states in america are poised to
outlaw abortion if roe is overturned
other states are promising they will be
safe havens i hope we're a little bit of
beacon of hope
a bright light
the california governor pledging
abortion will remain legal there this is
never having our lifetime they're taking
away rights
that have been affirmed over and over
again and well established they are
taking them away wake up america
if america is asleep it will surely soon
be shaken from its slumber a decision
just weeks away which has the potential
to further fracture this country martha
kellner sky news washington
now you'll have noticed we haven't had
any politicians on the program this
morning and that is because there's
dylan the dog of course uh and that's
the prime minister he's not just taking
him out for his morning walk he is in
fact taking him to the polling station
that looks like westminster hall
i think it is um polls have opened in
elections right across the uk today more
than 4 000 that was quick more than 4
350 seats are being contested in england
on over 140 councils with all of
scotland's 32 councils and all 22
councils in wales also holding local
elections folks in northern ireland are
electing representatives to the stormont
assembly polling stations close at 10
o'clock tonight we are expecting to also
see uh during the course of the
programme the leader of the opposition
and also the leader of the lib dems also
taking the opportunity to uh cast their
vote as is their democratic right
fossils dating back 66 million years
have been found outside a shopping mall
in bangkok they were first spotted by a
shopper who posted a photo
on social media now thai experts have
confirmed that the shells are genuine
and belong to marine creatures that
lived more than 60 million years ago in
total they found more than 70 fossils
embedded in the footpath ranging between
2 centimeters and 12 centimeters in size
meantime let's tell you what's going on
as far as the world health organization
is concerned it's warning of an obesity
crisis of epidemic proportions with more
than a million people dying in europe
each year and they say food delivery
apps supplying unhealthy food could be
one of the contributing factors what
does our next guest think about that
it's the gp dr david lloyd hello to you
dr lloyd
good morning i can't quite hear you but
i'm sure you are there
oh there we go i can hear you now i can
hear you know doctor what do you think
about the suggestions that um
people having deliverers and other
justice other uh delivery food systems
are available um is meaning that people
are getting fatter
well i think i think there is some
substance to that uh speaking personally
i broke my leg eight weeks ago on the
ski slope and so i've i've discovered
the the joy and the beauty of home
delivery apps food delivery apps uh and
i can tell you that it is incredibly
tempting to to over order and get large
quantities of food arrive instantly and
i can quite see how that can contribute
to uh to head to this obesity phenomenon
that we've got throughout the whole of
europe so yes i
i must say chimed with my personal
experience when i read that this morning
um how's the leg
it's getting better thank you very much
i can walk which is great i'm i'm uh
getting back to work today so it's a big
moment yes oh fantastic and did you did
you overreach
uh yes i certainly did overeat yes but i
i you've got to watch very carefully and
i think that's the that is the thing the
the the the delivery app that i used
actually does have the amount of
calories in each order you make and
that's no that's something i was quite
impressed with so you've got to watch
what you eat
and you've got to count your calories
and if you do that um i think you can
order safely and enjoy the
the absolutely amazing uh delivery times
that these these organizations now
provide i also i'm overwhelmed with
these services
welcome to the 21st century doctor um
have you noticed with your patients a
rise in obesity levels
it's it's it's a it's a really big thing
and it's
uh it's it really does fuel all sorts of
other diseases as well i think that's
the thing is it do you remember we got
into a big thing about smoking we know
that smoking causes lung cancer and
chronic lung disease and heart disease
and i think that message has got over
and we're slowly getting on top of the
smoking epidemic although
a stubborn few remains still smoking
i think we've got to get into that
mindset now with with being overweight
as well we've got to handle this very
sensitively but we do really need to
tackle the fact that as a country as a
whole as a
as a continent overall we are overweight
and that that overweight
is contributing to cancer to heart
disease uh
and and as you get older the the weight
really does count it has an effect on
your joints uh it reduces your ability
to exercise and you get into a sort of
vicious circle which
is jolly difficult to get out of so it
is something that we really ought to be
tackling okay doctor it's good to talk
to you good luck on your first day back
at work thanks for taking the time to
join us thank you very much thanks a lot
and i've also broken my foot which is
why i'm wearing trainers at the moment
and so i can't exercise either so i'm
also having to keep an eye on the
calories that i'm eating but i'm also
putting weight on
what can i say see you top of the app do
you hope
[Music]